mind your decisions i'm presh talwalkar
a mathematician writes numbers on a cube
on each face the mathematician writes a
positive integer
for clarification a positive integer is
a whole number greater than zero
on each vertex the mathematician writes
the product of its three adjacent faces
for example
in the upper right corner the
mathematician would write the number
that's equal to the product of x y and z
the mathematician does this for each of
the vertices
if the sum of all vertices is 154 what
is the sum of all faces
a similar problem was asked to 8th grade
students in taiwan
who were aged roughly 13 to 14 years old
i thank kieran in new zealand for the
suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
so how can we solve this problem
suppose the faces are labeled a b c d e
and f
suppose the face we're looking at is
labeled a we'll rotate the cube to label
the faces b
c and d
we'll rotate the cube again to get back
to a
on the left side we'll label it as e
and we'll label the face on the right as
f
let's now label each vertex
this vertex will be labeled abe
then if we rotate the cube
this vertex will be labeled abf
let's continue doing this for all the
vertices
now on the bottom we have the face d
and on the left side we have e
we still have d on the bottom and on the
right side we have f
so we can label these two vertices there
will be ade and adf
let's put these labels to the side and
now let's label the remaining four
vertices which will be on the opposite
side of the cube
so we'll look at face c and we'll label
each of these vertices
on the left side will be e
and on the right side will be face f
on the top of this will be face d
and on the bottom of c will be face b we
can use these labels to label each of
these vertices
starting from the lower left and going
clockwise we have c b e c d e c d f and
c b f
we want the sum of all of the vertices
let's sum the first four and the second
four separately
the first four we can factor out in a
and the second four we can factor out a
c
notice the remaining bracketed terms are
exactly equal in both of these equations
so we can further factor the sum as a
plus c multiplied by the bracketed term
let's continue factoring
the first two terms here have a common
factor of b
the next two terms have a common factor
of d
we then have a common factor of e plus f
so we get the following factorization
for the sum of all these vertices
it'll be a plus c multiplied by b plus d
multiplied by e plus f
now recall this is equal to 154
since each number is a positive integer
each bracketed term must be 2 or larger
and must be a factor of 154
154 factors into 2 times 7 times 11.
therefore the three bracketed terms must
be equal to two seven and eleven and the
sum of the bracketed terms will be the
sum of two seven and eleven
therefore we have a plus c plus b plus d
plus e plus f is equal to 2 plus 7 plus
11.
now if we look at these bracketed terms
we have one of each letter
therefore we have the sum of the faces
and this is equal to 20
and that's the answer the sum of the
numbers on the faces is equal to 20.
what a neat little problem
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on youtube
as always thanks for watching and thanks
for your support
[Music]
you